.
I WOULD RATHER GO DOWN SWINGING
THEN BEING GUN SHY.
>> NEXT QUESTION ON THE LEFT.
>> WHEN YOU HAVE GONE TO
YOUTUBE, WHEN WAS THE LAST TIME
YOU DID THAT AND WHAT DID YOU
CALL UP?
KLAY: [LAUGHTER]
IT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
I PROBABLY DID YESTERDAY,
ACTUALLY.
I REMEMBER BEING IN COLLEGE AND
WHEN YOU GO THROUGH A SHOOTING
SLUMP, YOU PULL UP THE VIDEO,
YOU PULL UP A GREAT GAME OF WHEN
EVERYTHING SEEMED IN UNISON AND
YOUR BODY WAS WORKING SO WELL,
IN THAT BLOCK -- THAT BALL WAS
FLOWING OFF YOUR FINGERTIPS.
GOSH, I PROBABLY JUST GAME SIX
KLAY BECAUSE THERE WERE SOME
VERY HIGH PRESSURE SITUATIONS I
WAS IN, AND I ENDED UP SHOOTING
THE BALL WELL.
WHEN YOUR BACK IS AGAINST THE